Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to the Night That Speaks.
Now, this is a very stylized, pixelated horror game as you can see right here.
Uh, and what I saw previews for this one, it reminded me very much of this game that I played a long time ago called 'Hide'.
Which I had to revisit, uh, just before I started with this one and the reason it reminds me of that-- ooho, hi?
Oh, what are you? (continuing) Is because the extreme low res., uh, of this game reminded me of, like, early GameBoy games
And this is a horror game--
(Odd noise, then silence)
...hi? o.o
Is that-
ooh ;(
Oh, oooh, *laughs* Alright this is-
This is the power that I was looking for because I saw a screenshot of this *giggles* -
Uh, hand being able to do the middle finger defense, which is the ultimate defense against all demons.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, so
ooh
Oh, I'm g-
(Deep chimes)
OoOkay.
It's time for the gong, man, where am I? Whoa! "'Z' to pick up"?
She was perfect in every way. She was intelligent, beautiful, and loved by everyone. She wanted to live forever.
OoOkay.
It is said that a strong sense of will can solve any problem in front of you. Hold 'Z' to exert your will.
Heh! Hegh, HUAGHAGAHG!!! That's my will, bitch!! You'd better back off, any monstrosities that are in this game
Alright, what is this? Oh- The doors open the other way.
Alright, Um I'm exerting my will as hard as I can! Channeling it through a single finger!
Alright.
Anyway.
Heh, heh, heh
So, that's hilarious- ooOoh. Whoa, is that a face? Or is that something el- AAUHGH
(Mark dies a bit inside)
OoOOW my neck!
I didn't think that was actually a face! ;(
I thought-
(Mark is weirded out by the noises)
Who's crying?! I'm not crying. Let me exert my will again. God damnit, what was that?
Obviously it was face, we've determined that it was a face
Someone in here is crying...
uugh
weird
Okay
Ah, yes, She always knew what to do. She didn't need to listen to anyone. But this darkness, it speaks. You must listen.
Yeah, I've been listening
I've been listening to th-
...moaning and the crying
Sounds like a bunch of bubble blowing babies!
Ooh.
Is that a thing?!
AHHHHG
Better not be a- der- HaAUHG! Oh, it was a thing. Okay! So, it was a thing but it was a dead thing so I don't need to worry about it.
She was brave and determined. The night called her forth and she came willingly.
Did she now?
What about this guy?
Probably not this guy...
He didn't come willingly.
EUGH EH
Anybody? Anybody out there- ooh oh. Whoa.
Okay another skelington. Why? A big jar. Why?
Uh oh!
(Odd and unsettling noise)
(Horrified Markimoo)
WAUGHHH!!! AAHHH WHAT ARE YOU!? TAKE MY WILL! OOOH TAKE MY STRONG WILL!! OOOEEEUGH
(*Why must I suffer*- Markiplier)
What was that supposed to be?
Hello?
Hi!
Did you not like my..... incredible will?
Huh?
Oh I can't see a thing. Oooh boy.
Uh oh.
(Odd and unsettling noise returns)
Is it coming? Oh Itsa coming
HUH
Yeaah! YEAH YEAH YEAH! TAKE THAT WILL!
Uh OH!
Uh oh!
Whoahaohoaha hey my will ain't strong enough forever, I guess.
EUHGGHIL
Aaap
Let me go down this way, please.
Oooh , jeez. Oooh , jeez. Oooh , jeez. Oooh , jeez.
Hello!
oh goD OH GOD OH GOD OH GOD  OH GOD OH
BLEUGH
Oh, jeez, this ain't good.
AAH! She new there was a way out. She list-learned to listen for the chains and for the growls-
EFUFUHEFUAH
Oooh!
Shit!
I didn't learn to live for the chains of the deep!
Alright, let's try that again.
I-I-d Thought, for some reason, in my mind, I thought that it paused the game when I was- (A device gets a notification)
Shut Up!
I'm trying to do a thing!
I thought that it paused the game when I was reading a note.
And I don't know why I thought that, but that's what I thought.
(Mark, very subtly, says) Boink!
Okay, so...
Where's it dropping me?
oooh
Yee
Okay.
So, I'm back here with the note about the chains
So I just gotta keep an ear out
Huuh
Well that sounds pretty unpleasant!
Let me go towards that sound!
Oh, good.
Oh, great.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, no. No, I'm coming for ya!
I'll help!
Uuuuuuuuh exerting my wiiillll
Yeah, that's what I thought. Okay.
Ohp! Okay.
Maybe I need to go down that way? I don't know.
Shh!
Uh oh!
(An odd and unsettling noise slowly grows louder.)
AAHH!
EXERTING MA WILL BABY!
AAH!
Oooh
Okay.
I- uh.
I can't side step?
I can't-
Yeah, I can't-
I-I can only turn, so I can't strafe around him while still looking at him.
I gotta be- I gotta be exerting all of my finger power directly into his face!
Alright, this time I intend to rush a little less headlong into death.
Because that seems to be the primary thing that's fucking up my steeze.
Tables
Do you have key- ooh computer!
Heh Fuck you computer! What'd you ever do for humanity?
FRUUCAUGH
Uh oh!
That ain't a good sound.
She is dead, but she doesn't know it.
I thought she wanted to live forever what is- AUAGHWHATAREYOU??
Whoa, I saw something there!
Whoa, where'd it go?
There was something there.
Press 'Z' to pick up- I already did that.
What was that?
I saw, like, teeth.
Uh oh.
Where is it? Where is it?
Oh, it's coming behind me, isn't it?
Euugh
I don't know where I'm going! I'm probably going in a fricken circle!
God damnit, I am aren't I.
Whoa! What is that?
Hellooo!
She was perfect in every way. She was eh-
Wha- I
She would live forever- I
Der I- Is that different than the one- I think that's different because the other one said she 'wanted' to live forever and that one said she 'would'
Uh oh.
AUGH!
AUGHJUSHUGA
AAaaAa I don't ike the sound of that...
Euugg
(Odd growling noise)
She worked hard- there was always a solution- this case was no different
Uh oh!
Euuugh!
WAauGH
Okay, now I have gone in a circle, that skeleton is like a land mark for-
It's behind me!
Wa UH!
That thing is definitely following me!
Oooh shit!
Oh shitty tits.
Get outta here, get outta here. Get- I don't know what you are or where you are or what you're doing
That guy'd better get out of here.
Better not StAUGhP
Uh oh!
EUUGH!
(Odd growling noise returns)
It's definitely after me!
WEEEUUGH
EUGH
Oh, god where am I now?
I bet it's a dungeon- oh it's a dead end!
Uh oh!
UH OH!
UH OH!!
UUUHHH OOOHH!!!
FuUUCK yOOAUGHOU
Did I get it?
Did I focus my will?
There was only static on the television. The computers were worse. There was something she couldn't see over there.
Yeah, no joke!
Oooh shit.
Oh, I'm fucked.
Oh, I am fuuuucked.
Oh, I ffuuUUUcKED
fffffffff
Ah, shit!
Ah, shit, dude!
GO AWAY!
I'm focusing my w-AUGH
Whoa!
Hey! I can't! How the fuck can I get away I can't get around him and LOOK AT HIM!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHH
(*why*- Markiplier)
Is he gone?
Whoooo, he's gone!
AUGH!
Whooa! Fuck off, dude!
Okay, so I can make them go away!
If I blast them with the middle finger!
*laughs* As hard as I can!
Euugh
Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Hey, whoa, hey, whoa, yeah that's right. You'd better get out of here.
Okay, so that's good!
'Cause that means eventually I'll be able to get a defense against these guys if they corner-
Okay, there's the door.
Hi!
And, bye!
Okay, so that's the door. So that means that somewhere in the middle section of all this stuff there's a key.
At least that would be my- my guess.
Man, these things are crawling.
ALA LALA! HA NANANANANANANANANANANANANANA-ooh
Mernererer
Alright.
Ummmm.
(Mark mumbles)
There must be a point to the notes. Like, there has to be a point to the notes.
Either...
It pieces together...
I mean, obviously, the notes are telling a story, but otherwise I'm just wandering lost so.
There's gotta be a reason.
Between the- Uh okay hang on!
God damnit stop that!
Between the lanterns....
There're
Hang on.
Go away, please.
Alright, between the lanterns, there was a cold wind and she fell through. There was something she couldn't see.
Okay, does that mean, like-
Ooh, hey.
That guy was quiet.
That was a stealthy dude, why is there something in front of my face?
Oh, okay, never mind.
So there's two lanterns here, so...
OOOOH!
OOOOOHHH!!!
Well, I would've that I would have walked over here anyway! God damnit, that was a big waste of time
Okay.
WHOA WHAT AM I DOING!?
How 'bout you?
Whoa, it's Hogwarts with the candles- okay.
Oh, key!!
How convenient!
Alrighty then
OOOOhh, what does that say?
YOU WE WILL KNOW PAIN!
Oh- You will know pain. Oh, I already know pain, thank you very much.
I know the pain of not knowing where the hell I'm going.
They gonna be able to go through there?
Well this hardly seems fair!
How am I supposed to be able to get-em out from-
But
NOOAAOOO
NOOOOAAOOOOOO
Oh, shiitaki.
I can't middle finger blast 'em through the wall!
OOpp
Maybe I can.
OOp! I did okay, never mind. I didn't know my finger blasting powers were that- never mind.
God dammit
Okay, we're going to carry on 'cause we've got the key. Then we're going to go over there.
And then we're gonna be able to open the dooOOOR
Finally progress, which would be nice.
Hello!
(Odd noises)
OOOH SHIT
OOOH DAMN IT
Is that the sound of someone laughing at me!?
You know I don't like that.
Oh it's coughing.
You heard the stories. You didn't care. You will live forever. Welcome to the darkness.
Oh! OH I can't move! Ah SHIT! AUUGH
MIDDLE FINGERS! ACTIVATE! AAAOOOHHGOD!
Is that my b- Oooohh
Oooow
huuuh
Ooooh I get it!
OOooh I get it!
Ooooh, I get it. OOOH! That was the end, holy shit!
She wanted to live forever
So she became a monster...
A never ending, always wandering the halls, monster.
And then I chased after her, looking for eternal youth, and I became a monster myself
So, that's interesting! A short, little, horror game with an interesting, like, hard-to-determine story.
Is that- Is that like a turkey on the wall, there?
A bird or something?
I don't know what that is. It looked gross.
So, thank you everybody, so much, for watching! If you want to check out old school pixelated horror games that I've played in the past
You can check the link in the description or click the annotation! So thanks again everybody for watching. And as always I will see you
In the next video.
BUH BYE!